bonsoir et bienvenue à tous voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce mardi un
tournant dans la crise avec l'iran un
rapport des services de renseignement
américains indiquent que téhéran à
cesser de fabriquer la bombe depuis
quatre ans la menace ne serait donc pas
imminente de george bush maintien
l'option militaire
les suites de la visite de nicolas
sarkozy en algérie le climat reste lourd
mais les affaires sont bonnes
des contrats de 5 milliards de dollars
ont été signés les conséquences de
l'euro fort
airbus se prépare à délocaliser une
partie de sa production aux états unis
d'autres sociétés comme dassault
aviation pourrait faire de même
la france montrée du doigt pour ses
performances scolaires une enquête
internationale classe les élèves au 19e
rang pour les sciences sur 30 pays
développés neuf places de perdues en
trois ans la zizanie au procès colonna
le berger corse à cusset amis de
comploter contre lui
il leur reproche de l'avoir disculper
trop mollement hier enfin un plan du
gouvernement contre le bruit des avions
en région parisienne l'altitude d'
approche avant l'atterrissage sera
relevé
les décollages de nuit seront surtaxés
c'est un virage et une surprise un
rapport des 16 agences de renseignement
américains y compris la cia remette à
plat toute la crise iranienne
il affirme que téhéran aurait gelé son
programme nucléaire militaire depuis
quatre ans autrement dit la bombe ne
serait pas pour demain george bush est
pris à contre-pied à washington alain de
chalvron aaron diamond l'iran était
dangereux est dangereuse et sera demain
toujours dangereux george bush persiste
et signe et pourtant il vient de subir
un camouflet de la part de ses propres
services secrets une synthèse regroupant
les analyses de 16 agences de
renseignement conclut je cite nous
jugeons avec un haut degré de confiance
qu'à l'automne 2003 téhéran a arrêté son
programme d'armes nucléaires
et pourtant l'idée que l'iran se
préparaient à mettre au point une arme
atomique sous couvert de nucléaire civil
était considérée comme acquise répéter
et répéter nous pensons qu'ils veulent
une arme atomique
c'est peu dire que le rapport des
services a plongé la maison blanche où
la question était plutôt faut-il ou non
attaquer l'iran dans l'embarras après
quelques heures de réflexion george bush
a choisi l'offensive
je considère que ce rapport est un
signal d'alarmé
l'iran avait un programme ils l'ont
arrêtée
ils peuvent donc parfaitement leur
prendre la meilleure des plots massy la
plus efficace c'est celle où l'on garde
toutes les options sur la table a noté m
qu'on le veuille ou non ce rapport rend
l'hypothèse d'une attaque de l'iran
avant la fin du mandat de george bush
hypothèse jugée jusqu'ici tout à fait
plausible
de plus en plus difficile 3 réactions
parmi beaucoup d'autres aujourd'hui
l'iran se félicite de ce rapport et
indique que l'onu doit être dessaisi du
dossier la france jugent nécessaire de
maintenir la pression
enfin à l'oeil le halage ans pour
l'énergie atomique estime que ce rapport
peut désamorcer la crise
il faut savoir que depuis plusieurs
années face notamment à cette menace les
etats-unis ont accéléré leur projet de
bouclier antimissile en clair un système
d'interception qui les rendraient quasi
invulnérable face à de telles attaques
pour la première fois l'une de nos
équipes a pu visiter ses installations
dans l'ouest des états unis envoyés
spéciaux gérard griesbeck pour une eau
giraudon
de l'avion impossible de distinguer les
lieux même en s'approchant l'endroit
semble désert rien n'indique que nous
sommes sur une base militaire
grande comme quatre fois la ville de
paris une des bases les plus secrètes
ici tout le monde travaille pour le
renseignement 5000 agents triés sur le
volet camouflé dans un hangar voici le
dernier joyau de la haute technologie
américaines
le missile anti-missile 12 mètres de
long la tête du missile porte en haut le
véhicule tueur il peut frapper le
missile ennemi de plein fouet ce système
marche bien on a confiance en nous et on
sera bientôt capable de le mettre en
place
mais ce n'est qu'une petite partie de
notre bouclier antimissile
les etats unis cherchent depuis des
années à mettre en place un bouclier
antimissile un bouclier qui pourrait
détruire tout engin lancé par un état
voyou
selon la terminologie officielle comme
l'iran ou la corée du nord
il s'agit de fabriquer une bulle
parfaitement étanche au dessus de l'eau
tête avec des centaines de radars et des
milliers de missiles repérer dans
l'espace
le missile ennemi est immédiatement
détruit une délégation de diplomates
européens découvrent maintenant un autre
haut lieu lui aussi tenu secret ici nous
sommes sur la base de lancement du
missile
nous nous préparons les opérations
d'interception régulièrement des tests
grandeur nature sont réalisés ici il ya
en moi pour le moment les échecs sont
nombreux on est encore loin d'un
bouclier antimissile ce projet pose
aussi des problèmes politiques alors
ainsi si un missile iranien file vers
washington
ce que l'iran est incapable de réaliser
aujourd'hui il survole l'europe
l'engin peut être détecté par des radars
américain installé en grande bretagne en
norvège au groënland et même en alaska
mais pour être plus efficace disent les
américains il faudrait aussi des radar
en république tchèque et des missiles en
pologne
ce que refuse catégoriquement vladimir
poutine d'où le risque d'une nouvelle
guerre froide avec en première ligne
lorgner la république tchèque nous ne
pouvons pas rester passifs nous ne
devons pas être seulement ceux qui
prennent les américaines nous devons
aussi être ce qui donne en échange ce
voyage est donc aussi une opération de
lobbying pour convaincre les pays
d'europe de l'est à 800 km de là sur une
autre base secrète une des plus grandes
oreilles du monde
un radar gigantesque et camoufler le
dernier né du projet américain fiable ou
pas le projet a deux avantages pour
l'amérique d'une part il permet une
meilleure intégration des pays d'europe
de l'est à la stratégie américaine
d'autre part il donne un coup de pouce à
l'économie en investissant 9 milliards
de dollars supplémentaires dans la
recherche civile et militaire
on en vient à la suite de la visite de
nicolas sarkozy en algérie leur était
aujourd'hui aux bonnes affaires 5
milliards de dollars de contrats ont été
signés notamment pour total gas de
français alstom mais la querelle sur le
passé continue à peser sur le voyage sur
place michael darmon stéphane guillemot
nicolas sarkozy à la recherche de
d'algérie d'albert camus
l'odeur des plantes aromatiques racle la
gorge chez sumo la chaleur règne sur le
site antique de tipasa évoqué par
l'écrivain dans un ses livres le chef de
l'état célèbre à sa manière le lien
entre les deux pays
il sait d'un lien entre les deux rives
de la méditerranée
il ya camus qui nous tient des deux
côtés place des martyrs la littérature
laisse la place à la politique
le ministre de l'intérieur algérien
commémore la guerre d'algérie avec
nicolas sarkozy mais pense que le
président français ne va pas assez loin
en parlant d'un système colonial qui a
été injuste
est-ce qu'en tout cas toujours est il
nécessaire concert est mise il est le
second
réponse quelques instants plus tard de
nicolas sarkozy la mienne car c'est au
niveau du président bouteflika qu'il
entend marquer la nouvelle relation
la signature d'un accord de coopération
sur le nucléaire civil se veut l'exemple
du nouveau chapitre qui s'écrit avec
l'algérie même si fait rarissime le
président bouteflika choisi de parler en
arabe
vous savez bien monsieur le président
l'amitié elle estime que je vous porte
de même que l'intérêt que je ne cesse
d'accorder au développement des
relations entre nos deux pays nous avons
une ardente obligation de bâtir ensemble
un avenir partagé nos deux peuples
l'exigent et l'attend nicolas sarkozy
abdelaziz bouteflika font le pari de
l'avenir
paris pourrait aider alger à devenir une
puissance émergente
même si une partie de la jeunesse se
détournent ici de la france nicolas
sarkozy qui pourrait par ailleurs être
au coeur d'une relance des négociations
sur la libération des otages des farc en
colombie et notamment d'ingrid
betancourt on l'a appris cet après-midi
le président colombien alvaro uribe va
en effet proposer au président français
de participer à une réunion avec la
guérilla
amaury guibert depuis la diffusion de
cette vidéo d'ingrid betancourt la
semaine dernière cette preuve de vie
attendue depuis plus de quatre ans les
choses semblent s'accélérer
aujourd'hui la colombie d'alvaro uribe
fait un geste d'importance elle va
proposer à nicolas sarkozy de participer
aux négociations avec les farc depuis
alger le président de la république a
confirmé cette invitation
quand donc entier ou véronique si l'on
considère ces pièces
dans les prochaines 48 heures l'elysée
pourrait donc recevoir cet homme carlos
restrepo
c'est lui qui était officiellement
chargé par le gouvernement colombien de
négocier un éventuel échange humanitaire
qui pourrait donc concerner une grève
est en cours pour sa fille mélanie tout
cela va dans le bon sens nouvelle j'ai
fait que les mots de maman que les
images qu'on a vus auparavant que fait
lécher les proches d'ingrid betancourt
avait regretté que le président
vénézuélien hugo chavez soient écartés
des négociations par la colombie mais
l'espoir renaît aujourd'hui avec ce
possible passage de témoin nicolas
sarkozy
et puis toujours à ce chapitre
diplomatique sachez que nicolas sarkozy
a déclenché de vives critiques à gauche
pour ses félicitations à vladimir
poutine après les élections en russie
c'est moscou qui a révélé ce coup de
téléphone
le parti socialiste parle de cynisme
rappelons que la plupart des pays
occidentaux ont critiqué le déroulement
de ce scrutin
économie avec les conséquences de l'euro
fort c'est tout un symbole
l'européen airbus confirme son projet de
délocaliser une partie de sa production
aux états unis pour éviter un
renchérissement des coûts dans le même
secteur dassault aviation pourrait faire
de même
david boeri delphine pas rick miller
plusieurs centaines d'avions vendus en
quelques jours un record historique le
mois dernier au dernier salon
aéronautique de dubaï aujourd'hui airbus
à plus de 3000 avions dans son carnet de
commandes plus de six années de
production
une production facturés en euros mais
les avions eux sont vendus en dollars la
forte hausse de l'euro inquiète les
dirigeants de l'entreprise qui
n'hésitent plus à parler de
délocalisation crois qu'on n'aura pas le
choix
le taux du dollar est tel que il nous
conduit à rechercher des coûts en
dollars
c'est à dire à aller vers les pays
soient bas coûts soient les pays de la
zone dollar et les etats unis se
délocaliser aujourd'hui ce n'est plus un
tabou pour l'industrie aéronautique
européenne et française ce n'est plus un
tabou et ça risque de devenir une
obligation car les bénéfices s'effondre
en euros démonstration avec l'a320 vendu
à un prix catalogue de 73 millions de
dollars il rapportait il ya un an
56 millions d'euros à airbus
contre seulement 48 6 millions
aujourd'hui soit 7,4 millions d'euros de
moins par appareil les bénéfices sont
donc grignoter par la valeur du dollar
par rapport à la monnaie européenne
airbus veut donc produire en dehors de
la zone euro pour jouer sur le même
terrain que son concurrent américain
boeing
oui il a été fabriqué avec des heures
qu'ils étaient 20 à 30% moins cher à
qualification égale tout simplement
parce que c'était les heures en dollar
certains sous traitants d'airbus ont
déjà franchi le pas en rachetant ou en
installant des usines en afrique du nord
ou en chèques
l'actualité sociale avec la deuxième
phase des négociations entre les
syndicats et la direction de la sncf et
un représentant de l'état sur la réforme
des régimes spéciaux de retraite
on a parlé aujourd'hui de l'indexation
des pensions et de la fameuse décote
un accord est intervenu sur la création
d'un nouvel échelon d'ancienneté
des rassemblements étaient organisés sur
les sites ferroviaires pour peser sur
ces discussions ce débat sur l'âge de la
retraite vous le savez sera relancé l'an
prochain pour tous les salariés
et si beaucoup souhaitent partir plus
tôt en général dans les métiers pénibles
d'autres souhaitent partir plus tard en
général dans les professions
intellectuelles
c'était le sens d'un séminaire en forme
de pied de nez organisé aujourd'hui à
l'académie des sciences en présence de
quelques célèbre octogénaire reportage
séverine lebrun dominique bonnet ça fait
trente et un nom qu'il égrène
inlassablement la liste de ses
chroniqueurs
philippe bouvard soixante dix huit ans
et toujours autant d' enthousiasme
aujourd'hui il travaille encore dix
heures par jour
le journaliste fait exception à la règle
mais il avait raison je ne prétends pas
non plus que tout le monde doit
travailler aussi tard et ça n'est
valable que parce que j'ai eu la chance
le privilège d'exercer un métier passion
et que les passions ça disparaît pas
avec l'âge la passion du professeur
tubiana c'est la lutte contre le cancer
87 ans tous les jours au bureau même
s'il met deux fois plus de temps
qu'avant pour y aller il ne manque pas
une journée pour être tout à fait
honnête ya des jours où j'en ai un peu
marre mais je me dis que si je me laisse
aller et bien petit à petit je ne ferai
plus rien et que ça sera le début de la
déchéance
alors travailler plus longtemps
serait-il bon pour la santé
c'est ce que pense la très sérieuse
académie des sciences d'autant que
l'espérance de vie augmente chaque année
de deux mois et demi
intellectuel sur ce qu'on appelle la
commission ce délire l'a fait qu'il dise
à prendre sur la mémoire toute une série
d'études qui montrent peu de conserver
l'activité est bon pour la qualité de
cette activité
des considérations qui sont moins
valable pour les métiers les plus
physiques
rappelons qu'aujourd'hui au delà de 55
ans seuls trois français sur dix sont
toujours au travail
en bref le mouvement de contestation de
la loi pécresse entre dans sa cinquième
semaine avec un certain essoufflement
il a connu aujourd'hui un sursaut à
l'occasion d'une journée de mobilisation
en compte 27 sites universitaires
bloqués et des manifestations lycéennes
étaient organisées un peu partout comme
ici à paris
imaginiez bernie mériaux des dizaines
d'établissements ont été bloqués des
lycées français épinglé par ailleurs par
la grande étude internationale de l'
ocde sur le niveau scolaire comparé dans
les pays développés elle est menée tous
les trois ans non seulement la france
n'a pas amélioré ses performances mais
elle a encore perdu plusieurs places au
classement elle pointe au 19e rang sur
30 pour les sciences par exemple nabila
taboury olivier robert pierre gilles de
gennes georges charpak albert fert tu
trois scientifiques français trois prix
nobel de physique
mais qu'en est il des lycéens laurier ou
bonnet d'âne
les résultats ne sont guère brillants
c'est une étude de l' ocde qui le dit le
niveau des élèves français est même en
recul par rapport à il ya quatre ans en
sciences on passe de la 10e à la 19e
place en français de la 14e à la 17e
même constat pour les mathématiques sur
41 pays
la france a tout juste la moyenne sont
en seconde
la plupart espèrent suivre des études de
sciences ce classement les fait rougir 2
août
parfois les professeurs pensent d'abord
à ternay le programme et font ensuite
passé
l'intérêt des élèves et ce qui parfois
est gênant qui s'appelle le prix de la
croiser le classement pisa était établi
tous les trois ans il évalue un
échantillon d'élèves âgés de 15 ans la
finlande reste toujours en tête suivi du
canada et du japon
l'écart entre la france et le premier
est l'équivalent en connaissance d'une
année scolaire
les spécialistes de l'éducation ou leurs
explications
nous avons choisi une formule de collège
unique qui est très spéciale avec
beaucoup de redoublement des classes de
niveau dans un certain nombre
d'établissements peu d'enseignements
individualisé et on voit que ces choix
là ne sont pas les plus efficaces moins
d'heures de cours plus de soutien ce
sont les pistes du ministre de
l'éducation
en attendant pour l'élève france
l'ensemble est trop moyen peut donc lui
faire noyer cette baisse de niveau
s'explique surtout par le plus grand
nombre d'élèves en difficulté on estime
que 120 mille lycéens sortent chaque
année du système sans diplôme ni
qualification
pourtant les solutions existent un
réseau d'établissements à encadrement
renforcé obtient des résultats probants
c'est un gros investissement c'est vrai
mais il porte ses fruits c'est le
dossier de cette édition il est signée
jenny briffa didier down ce pavillon de
banlieue sans prétention est en réalité
un collège l'un des plus petits de
france on y accueille les enfants dont
on ne veut plus ailleurs je peux pas
répondre deux à la fois - trop turbulent
à 12 ans certains ne savent ni lire ni
écrire
ils ont souvent été renvoyés de leur
établissement on mettra ça me met dessus
puisqu'il n'arrivait pas à les faire je
me renfermer de suez
ma chienne
aux jets que le d1 d2 et des 0 et alors
dans ta tête tu disais que tu étais nul
bon j'étais venu ici
si on dit on attendait monsieur est ce
que vous pouvez faire une pause par
exemple ils vont la faire car ici ils ne
sont que 12 par classe ça très bien
kevin t'as pas besoin de moi il continue
sa ferrari chez nous ils ont ils ont
perdu confiance
ils sont très mal à l'aise et donc la
première chose à faire c'est de les
remettre en confiance donc de leur
donner des exercices qui savent déjà
faire pour se rendre battu assez lucide
tu sais faire ça et puis du et puis
après on augmente la difficulté
le collège romero fondé à la fin des
années 70 bénéficient de subventions du
département et de l'église catholique
quatorze adultes encadrent 48 élèves un
moyen de répondre à chaque question en
classe mais aussi de veiller à la
discipline
bonjour guillaume j'ai eu un problème
avec le soulman dans la khl hasard ici
on l'appelle le directeur par son prénom
et en cas de problème il est toujours
disponible juste enfants de me traiter
la moindre insulte est sanctionné on
laisse passer beaucoup de choses mais on
explique bien aux élèves qui a des
limites a pas dépasser et à partir du
moment où ces limites sont bien fixe et
bien montré clair clairement vu là par
contre on y rit gît là dessus plus des
trois quarts de ces jeunes réussissent à
retourner dans leur établissement
d'origine ou intégrer une formation
professionnelle elle va parfois les
conduire bien loin de leur banlieue
d'origine au coeur de paris dans la nex
de la tour d'argent le prestigieux
restaurant pascal et ans et ap cuisine
l'an dernier ils étaient justement élève
au collège romero
première émulsion le relais au début on
n'aime pas trop l'école et après on
bosse on le dit quand on est dans le
travail on veut on peut faire q l'air on
aimera vont partir à l'école mais c'est
pas possible
et pourtant dyslexiques parce qu'elle a
longtemps eu une scolarité chaotique
mais il a très vite su travailler seul
ne sont pas encore autonome
c'est pourquoi ils sont un terme dans
sept autres établissements privés de la
fondation d'auteuil
est-ce que la rize 8000 jeunes en
difficulté moi je veux voir quelque
chose sur la table c'est pas possible qu
est rien
tous les soirs l'étude est obligatoire
quand on était chez nous on a les doors
ont été le bordel on était les tags de
potes
il sera composé calais d'or l'on pense
aller dehors mais comme on sait que ne
pourra pas les dehors sans a lancé
l'album du sénat
et pour cause une fois dans leur chambre
ils reçoivent tous la visite de leurs
éducatrices cette voie je vérifie donc
si l'on fait les voir on études et
apprennent qu'on vérifie le sac ne court
pour le lendemain et pascaline repassera
jusqu'à ce que les devoirs soient faits
chaque année en france 120 mille jeunes
sortent du système éducatif sans aucune
qualification sauf peut-être pour ceux
qui ont pu intégrer une école de la
dernière chance justice avec la
quatrième semaine du procès d'yvan
colonna le ton s'est nettement refroidie
aujourd'hui entre l'accusé et ses amis
corse yvan colonna leur reproche de ne
pas l'avoir innocenté avec assez de
conviction hier
il les accuse de comploter contre lui
face à cette situation son avocat
demande une reconstitution sur les lieux
à ajaccio reportage dominique verdeilhan
jean-marc new look osé le demander ou
faire marche arrière les avocats d'yvan
colonna ont tranché la cour d'assises de
paris doit se rendre à ajaccio sur les
lieux du crime
il y a trop dit style d'incertitude
d'incohérent sur les circonstances de
l'assassinât deux ou trois hommes
étaient sur les lieux
le procès n'a rien éclaircies selon la
défense alors distille on n'a rien à
perdre on veut plaider l'innocence
par le doute mais on veut aller sur
place cette affaire là le doute ne
profitera pas plus gras présomption
d'innocence dont nous sommes obligés de
prendre tous les risques ne les prenons
tous avec la conviction que toute
manière il ne peut en recevoir sorte que
la vérité la vérité c'est qu'il n'y
avait qu'un besoin au contact du préfet
et qu' aucun une demande qui n'a pas de
sens dit en choeur les parties civiles
des avocats qui espère que la cour qui
se prononcera demain ne tombera pas dans
le piège et cela n'a aucun intérêt
factuel c'est uniquement une sorte de
piège tendu pour que la cour d'assises
et à se prononcer sur quoi sur
respectez-vous les droits de la défense
où avez vous déjà une opinion une
demande qui intervient le jour même où
yvan colonna dit tout haut ce qu'il
pense des membres du commando
ils viennent dire que je n'y étais pas
mais sans explication cela ne me
satisfait pas j'ai le sentiment qu'ils
ont fait le choix de me laisser
condamner à perpétuité pour protéger
quelqu'un d'autre c'est un aveu yvan
colonna n'est pas convaincu par ce qui
le disculpe les suite des émeutes de
villiers-le-bel la police est décidé à
tout faire pour retrouver ceux qui ont
tiré sur les forces de l'ordre
elle promet de rémunérer les
renseignements utiles
quatre mille tracts ont été diffusés
aujourd'hui dans les boîtes aux lettres
sur place c'est une première pour ce
genre d' enquête deux tonnes de cannabis
ont été interceptés dans deux voitures
près de bordeaux la drogue était
acheminée par le système du go fast
il s'agit de véhicules très puissant qui
roulent à toute vitesse entre l'espagne
et la france précédé d'une voiture
complices qui ouvre la route
il ne s'arrête nulle part ni aux péages
ni aux barrages routiers les gendarmes
espèrent avoir donné un coup d'arrêt à
ces pratiques
enquête sur place francis mazoyer le
dispositif est impressionnant
une trentaine d'hommes armés de fusils à
pompe ces gendarmes protègent leurs
dernières saisies de drogue
ils craignent une attaque commando de
trafiquants hyperviolents prêt à tout
pour récupérer leur marchandise dans ses
cartons deux tonnes de résine de
cannabis la plus importante prise
réalisée en france dans des véhicules de
tourisme
les malfaiteurs qui roulent de nuit
entre l'espagne et la france dans des
voitures volées ne prennent même pas la
peine de dissimuler la drogue
la voici en tasser un peu partout dans
ses berlines
ultra rapide ap légaux face une autre en
1852 shit qui à l'achat représente une
somme d'un million cinq cent mille euros
environ et à la revente et bien il faut
facilement étudié par deux ou par trois
de mémoire de gendarme
c'est exceptionnel c'est la première
fois qu'une telle quantité saisie
un convoi go fast lancé à plus de 200
kilomètres heure c'est un véhicule de
tête des voitures de transport et des
voitures balais qui font barrage à l'arc
et voilà comment une tentative
d'interception par les douanes a
récemment échoué dans les landes les
convoyeurs à court d'essence ont
finalement laissé les bolides chargé de
cannabis dans cette rue de cestas en
gironde
c'est là que la gendarmerie des a
retrouvé les gendarmes ont tout aussi
des véhicules rapides mais ces
convoyeurs souvent cagoulés armés et
sous l'emprise de la drogue sont très
difficiles à arrêter
il n'hésite pas à foncer sur les
véhicules de police au canard mort y
voir des douanes
il franchissait les péages le seul
endroit où ils peuvent être vulnérables
c'est sur les stations service où ils
sont contraints de s'arrêter pour faire
le plein en carburant en france
la technique du go-fast se développe
depuis quatre cinq ans au début des
autorités était dépassé puis des
interceptions se sont multipliés comme
ici en août 2006 à hendaye
cette voiture avait tout de même forcé
un pea en gironde
la gendarmerie enquête afin de retrouver
les convoyeurs de la marchandise qui
vient d'être saisie après avoir été
analysés par la police scientifique
la drogue a été convoyé sous bonne
escorte vers une déchetterie les deux
tonnes de résine de cannabis ont été
entièrement détruites
si vous habitez près d'un aéroport vous
le savez les nuisances sonores du
transport aérien sont parmi les plus
pénibles et bien le gouvernement vient
de lancer un plan pour la région
parisienne
l'altitude d' approche avant
l'atterrissage sera relevé de 300 m les
décollages de nuit seront surtaxés
nicolas lemarignier damien louvet des
rues de champlain ou piste
à peine 3 km alors quand le gouvernement
propose de faire voler les avions 300
mètres plus haut pour diviser le bruit
par deux je pense que pour championnat
c'est plus loin à 15 20 km des pistes
que la mesure sera efficace au dessus du
toit de ghislaine qu'une yers par
exemple un avion toutes les minutes en
provenance ou à destination de roissy je
crois que c'est encourageant parce que
c'est la première fois quand même qu'il
ya quelque chose de significatif qui a
l'air de se dessiner
petit bémol il faut revoir les
procédures d'atterrissage et ça ça n'est
pas simple du tout pour le contrôleur
c'est un peu plus compliqué parce que
réguler des avions qui sont en descente
et bien par rapport aux trois aéroports
il y en a qui montrent qu'ils défendent
qui passe à travers c'est un peu plus
compliqué les mesures annoncées visent
aussi les nuisances des vols de nuit qui
pourrissent la vie des riverains
alors les médecins et propose les
barbituriques des somnifères
mais ça compense papillons blancs - une
fatigue qui s'installe
le gouvernement propose de taxer plus
lourdement les vols entre 18h et 22h pas
suffisant les associations la majorité
des riverains veulent en tout premier
que
l'on arrête les vols de nuit qu'on crée
un véritable couvre-feu sur roissy
charles de gaulle
la taxe ainsi prélevé 15000 euros pour
un boeing 747 financera l'insonorisation
de certains logements très proche des
aéroports
aujourd'hui le but n'est certainement
pas de supprimer les nuisances mais au
moins de les rendre plus supportable à
l'étranger d'abord ces manifestations
anti eta en ce moment même à madrid pour
dénoncer le meurtre d'un garde civil
espagnol en france il ya quelques jours
l'ensemble de la classe politique qui
avaient appelé à défiler la foule est
restée silencieuse pendant plusieurs
minutes auparavant ce matin le premier
ministre c'est luis zapatero s'était
rendu au chevet de l'autre garde civil
grièvement blessé et qui est
hospitalisées à bayonne
le nouvel outil de la politique suisse
pour tenter de décourager l'immigration
il s'agit de la vidéo
le pays a fait tourner un clip destiné
au nigeria et au cameroun
objectif montrer que de nombreuses
difficultés attendent les nouveaux
arrivants une initiative on s'en doute
diversement appréciée arnaud boutet
thierry simonet le film se veut un
électrochoc
il met en scène une conversation entre
un père en afrique et son fils en europe
le mans se veut rassurant j'ai fait des
courses dans la journée provocation
volontaire immigrés égale délinquants en
fait le jeune homme vit sous la pluie
dans la rue
la suisse finance le film l'afrique le
diffuse un message
la confédération n'est pas un pays de
cocagne ils arguent les immigrés du
nigeria et du cameroun ne peuvent
demander l'asile
alors ils se retrouvent dans
l'illégalité travail au noir c'est
justement ce que nous voulons éviter
déjà lors des récentes législatives le
premier parti politique celui de
christophe clochet représentait une
affiche résolument xénophobe avec un
mouton noir désignant l'immigré le film
va-t-il trop loin en suisse certains le
jugent raciste
c'est le racisme officiel c'est ça qui
me fait peur c'est comme dans les années
30 quand le racisme et se découvre peu à
peu et devient politique gouvernementale
et je trouve ça détestable et c'est
dangereux
comment ce message est il perçu en
afrique exemple à dakar où le rêve n'est
pas suisse mais plutôt espagnol quelles
que soient les dangers gagné personnes
qui prenaient des voisins ou des amis
qui décède en mer et pourtant ça les
empêche pas de prendre les pirogues
au moment de partir ça risque de ne pas
peser lourd sur la balance mais sa peau
mais on les sensibilise et même si ce
n'est que sur dix y en a deux qui vont
abandonner le projet la commission
européenne participe au financement du
film et assume sa position elle fait de
la lutte contre l'immigration
l'un de ses principaux objectifs en bref
encore et à l'étranger l'esprit de paix
d'annapolis la semaine dernière semble
déjà loin israël annonce aujourd'hui
l'agrandissement d'une colonies à
jérusalem-est 300 nouveaux logements en
construction
rappelons qu israël est censé geler
toutes ses activités de colonisation
dans les territoires occupés retour en
france avec l'inquiétude des producteurs
de betteraves à sucre leur assemblée
générale avait lieu aujourd'hui à paris
notre pays est le troisième producteur
mondial mais le secteur est en crise car
bruxelles impose une diminution de la
production de sucre
les exploitants mise sur les
biocarburants sophie brune annie tri
boire
le lieu-dit la sucrerie en picardie
l'endroit tire son nom de l' usine de
fabrication de sucre de betterave
implantée à la fin du 19e mais l'an
prochain l'usiné doit fermer la centaine
de salariés subi la restructuration du
secteur vie qu'elle adore ce qui s'est
passé les joueurs qu'on a eu et c'est
pour leur offre là une europe sociale
c'est nous qui trinquons car la réforme
a été décidée à bruxelles
l'europe doit baisser sa production de
sucre de 30% pour se conformer à une
décision de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce
conséquence pour ce groupe sur ses cinq
usines françaises
l'une va disparaître chaque entreprise
devra le faire
soit on le fait et des dés 2008 soit
nous serons contraints de le faire sans
aide
en 2010 l'objectif de bruxelles et
notamment de faire de la place aux pays
pauvres en produisant moins en europe
un argument difficile à accepter pour
les salles à sa part d'un bon sentiment
mais c'est clair que la fermeture aura
aussi des conséquences pour les 1400
planteurs de betteraves qui fournissent
la sucrerie michel lapointe à une
exploitation de 170 hectares il va
diminuer la surface consacrée aux
betteraves la culture de la betterave ne
représente que 15 à 20% des possibilités
des surfaces de la région
ce qui fait que les gens ont l'habitude
de faire d'autres cultures et ils se
reconvertissent partiellement sur
d'autres cultures de production l'autre
solution pour les planteurs c'est le
biocarburant à une vingtaine de
kilomètres de là cette usine flambant
neuf produit de l'éthanol
un bon moyen pour ce producteur de sucre
de se diversifier
on fait à la fois du sucre en quantité
moindre et on compense ces réductions de
quantité par un développement d'alcool
de l'éthanol j'ai fait que nos activités
nos entreprises peuvent encore se
déployer cependant cette reconversion et
partiel faute de débouchés
les biocarburants de compenser en partie
la baisse de production de sucre
en bref des précisions sur la prime à la
cuve annoncé le mois dernier pour
compenser l'envolée des prix du pétrole
elle sera rappelons le de 150 euros eh
bien le bénéfice ira à 680 mille foyers
non imposables
c'est ce qu'a indiqué la ministre de
l'économie christine lagarde
quand l'opéra cherche à attirer un
nouveau public c'est une version
monumentale de carmen qui est proposée
ce soir sur la scène
la très grande scène de bercy à paris le
spectacle est actuellement en tournée en
france marie-hélène bono frédérick
basile vous endroit pour un opéra 2500
places à zenit pour carmen grand
orchestre et ordinateurs des tonnes de
matériel son lumière et vidéo
sur scène et en coulisse 200 personnes
chanteurs danseurs et musiciens 17
nationalités différentes
oprah maspie temps dans l'opéra et pour
tout le monde
il ne doit pas s'adresser à une élite i
dans des salles spécialisées et cet
opéra monumental qui est carmen est
importante pour que les gens viennent à
nos terrains et la pression au point et
ça marche
hier soir pour la première quelques 2000
personnes ont répondu présentes au
zénith de dijon plus pour le show que
pour le livrer
carmen est urgent qu'elle ne parle pas
français
une artiste en tournée qui a l'habitude
d'interpréter carmen istanbul
je joue quand même depuis trois ans mais
c'est une production très nouvelle et
très très grosses productions qui arrive
en france
ça ressemble plus à un show un grand
show
le but est aussi d'attirer les jeunes de
l'opéra dans un génie ça vous gêne pas
ça peut surprendre au début mais
finalement vu la qualité de la mise en
scène et
et puis la qualité également de l'or
qu'istres finalement si c'est du gros
spectacle le plus que de la grande
musique pas sûr que les puristes
apprécié mais après tout ce n'est pas le
but
en bref une image de handball et du
mondial qui se déroule actuellement en
france l'équipe de france justement se
qualifie pour le deuxième tour après sa
victoire face au kazakhstan hier soir 31
à 20 de victoire donc pour les français
qui affronte ce soir la croatie avant de
refermer cette édition je vous en
rappelle deux des principaux titres peut
être un nouvel espoir pour ingrid
betancourt
le président colombien uribe propose à
nicolas sarkozy de participer à une
réunion avec la guérilla des farc
et puis un tournant dans la crise avec
l'iran un rapport des services de
renseignement américains indiquent que
téhéran à cesser de fabriquer la bombe
depuis quatre ans la menace ne serait
donc pas imminente
george bush maintien l'option militaire
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
laurent romejko 20h50 un nouveau très
beau voyage vu du ciel
troisième volet des voyages de yann
arthus-bertrand aujourd'hui à la
rencontre des agriculteurs du monde
entier
à demain
l'info en continu
c'est aussi sur france 2 fois fr